mesdames et messieurs bonsoir des
embouteillages considérable marque les
retours de la toussaint et pour les
responsables de la circulation routière
les automobilistes n'ont qu'à s'en
prendre à eux-mêmes face à ces
difficultés voyez c'est un jugement
sévère il avait été formellement
déconseillé de rouler notamment région
parisienne entre 15h et 22h
or c'est justement dans cette tranche de
temps que le flot des voitures a
commencé à déferler
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le colonel tahar
axa les principaux responsables du
centre de rosny sous bois
les nouvelles dramatiques nous viennent
de téhéran plus d'une cinquantaine de
personnes de l'ambassade des etats-unis
en iran sont repris en otage par des
centaines d'étudiants et des gardiens de
la révolution islamique
les ravisseurs disent qu ils ne rendront
les otages que si les états unis leur
livre le shah d'iran qui se trouve dans
une clinique américaine après une grave
opération nous allons entendre les
dernières informations de terrain puis
les réactions du gouvernement américain
qui est placé devant un grave dilemme
inconditionnels américain firme si les
états unis n'extradent le choc la
ceinture déclaration est venue s'ajouter
la voie de la ville sainte
l'imam khomeiny soutient l'action les
experts constituant aussi de négociation
capus ce soir entamé le chargé
d'affaires américain monsieur bruce lee
games annonce donc des v6 tout avait
commencé ce matin vers 10 heures quand
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants ont
sauté les murs de l'ambassade sans que
le service d'ordre iraniens réagissent
en attaque et armés de gourdins les
bâtiments de la chancellerie
les annexes et la résidence après ce
genre de deux heures de résistance les
marines américains se sont rendus défend
ce soir aux cages vous retenu comme le
dit washington
des étudiants ont publié trois
communiqués ont refusé les mercenaires
qui en tiraient des grenades
lacrymogènes dénoncé le centre national
intériale east et assuré qu'elle et
l'incident n'avait pas fait de victime à
washington monsieur martial soulman
approche conseillé les yeux fardés cyrus
vance était il ya une heure l'indicé
d'une grande émission télévisée nous ne
savons rien pour le moment sur la sphère
de terrain avait-il confessé
impression confirmée par ces paroles
voiture les personnes retenues par le
plus bas du jour n'est pas critique et
nous ressortissants n'ont pas subi le
mode d'une prudence illustre la
complexité de la fère et l'embarras qui
donne une heure et par l'arrivée du chat
aux etats-unis principal est à new york
aurait suivi une réaction de la terre
n'est pas seulement les actions et la
négociation délicate prévient le
visiteur électeurs retenus dans leur
ambassade
enfin sous la pression mais prenons pas
la porte à maintenir car faire accuser
france après le prendre la toussaint la
vie politique doit reprendre son cours
normal à partir de demain a dit la
première question que l'on peut se poser
c'est de savoir comment vont évoluer les
choses à la suite du suicide de monsieur
robert boulin dont les obsèques ont eu
lieu hier en présence de dix mille
personnes dans les landes aviv entre
notons qu'une dame de dunkerque une dame
à shell affirme que sa mère a acheté il
ya déjà quinze ans le fameux terrain de
ramatuelle qu'un ritournelle aurait donc
vendu maintes et maintes fois dont une
fois au ministre disparu le rôle d'henri
tournai devient de plus en plus obscurs
et madame richesse apportée est bien
huilée au début cette affaire étaient
une affaire judiciaire mais s'il faut je
crois que nous en reparlions ce soir
c'est parce qu'il apprit que vous le
disiez des dimensions politiques qui
vont sans doute reconnaître dans les
jours qui viennent de nouveaux
développements mais revenons au début il
n'y avait pas en fait il n'y a pas
d'affaires boulin au début c'était
essentiellement une affaire rouge
nom du premier notaire qui s'est occupé
du tristement fameux terrain de
ramatuelle
et puis cette affaire est devenue une
affaire henri tournet et c'est henri
tournet qui a voulu la transformer en
une affaire boulin par des déclarations
qui mettait en cause le comportement du
ministre du travail monsieur boulin ne
devrait d'ailleurs pas être entendu
comme témoin dans cette histoire
cependant le principal intérêt de
l'enquêté judiciaire qui continue sera
l'examen critique des insinuations de
monsieur henri tourner mais monsieur
boulin souhaitait être entendu comme
témoin lui même eh bien oui le souci
principal de robert boulin dans toute
cette affaire était que la lumière soit
faite qu'elle soit fait le plus
rapidement possible et s'il se
renseignait s'il l'est intervenait ce
n'était pas pour que cette affaire soit
étouffée 7 est au contraire pour qu'elle
soit accélérée c'est dans cet esprit
même dans ce souci que robert boulin a
même pris des contacts avec des
journalistes de minutes des journalistes
du canard enchaîné effectivement comme
vous le disiez il souhaitait être
entendu comme témoin il a fait une
démarche en ce sens auprès du garde des
sceaux monsieur alain peyrefitte le 18
juin dernier et voici pourquoi pour
qu'un ministre puisse être entendu il
doit disposer d'une autorisation qui lui
est accordée par un décret du garde des
sceaux
après une délibération du conseil des
ministres or monsieur robert boulin
aurait voulu éviter cette procédure et
il souhaitait prendre les devants en
demandant lui-même à être entendue mais
qu'ils soient cités ou qu'il prenne les
devants il lui fallait de toute façon
passer par cette procédure
donc assez compliqué je crois qu'on peut
dire que robert boulin était obsédé par
cette affaire et des témoignages de ses
proches nous disent que depuis deux mois
il ne sait c'est d'en parler tous les
soirs à sa famille mais cependant
lorsqu'il abordait ce problème avec ses
amis politiques il affichait une
certaine sérénité sur dix est il de son
innocence et sûr de sa transparence ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de ses amis politiques regrettent
d'être passé à côté de ce drame dont il
n'avait pas su deviner toute la gravité
vous parlez d'un développement eh bien
oui et je crois qu'on peut dire que ces
jours ci les regards se tournent vers le
rpr qui se trouve accusé disons par une
certaine rumeur d'avoir eu intérêt à
porter atteinte à la réputation de l'un
des siens qui s'étaient écartés
sa ligne politique alors parmi les
déclarations et les rumeurs je crois
qu'on peut retenir deux choses d'abord
l'article l'éditorial de notre confrère
philippe alexandre qui samedi rtl
expliqué qu'il était certain de bonnes
sources qu aux environs du 15 septembre
des dirigeants du rpr s'étaient réunis
et avait décidé de révéler à la presse
un certain nombre d éléments de ce
dossier et puis on dit aussi dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale que le
mercredi 24 octobre jour des questions
d'actualité et robert boulin c'était
donc quelques jours avant son suicide
assis à côté de monsieur maurice
plantier secrétaire d'état aux anciens
combattants lui avait fait des
confidences et lui avait dit en
particulier que la campagne qui se
déclenchait contre lui venaient de la
rue de lille c'est à dire du ciel du rpr
et monsieur boulin aurait même citer un
nom alors au rpr on s'indigne on dément
et j'aurais voulu avoir une interview
d'un des responsables de ce mouvement
mais ce responsable m'a dit tout à
l'heure que la campagne contre son
mouvement avait pris une ampleur telle
qu'il fallait que les dirigeants du
mouvement se réunissent pour savoir
quelle réplique il allait apporter à
cette campagne
c'est ce qu'ils feront demain dès 9
heures on peut dire je crois qu'une
bataille politique est en train de
s'engager autour de robert boulin et que
dans cette campagne les tentations
seront peut-être force d'interpréter la
pensée du ministre a disparu pour
monsieur pierre mauroy le maire
socialiste de lille qui s'exprimait sur
rtl
il est clair que ces événements marquent
la fin d'un régime il ya trop de trafic
dit monsieur roy et d' influence de
toute nature si la gauche était en état
et rassembler at il poursuivi ce régime
tomberait comme une feuille morte
quant à monsieur mitterrand il
participait cet après midi au congrès
des élus socialistes arras faisant
allusion au conflit entre conseillers
municipaux socialistes des communistes
des conflits qui troublent actuellement
certaines municipalités d'union de la
gauche
il a estimé que personne n'avait le
droit de remettre en cause le contrat
municipal de 1977 valable pour six ans
le parti socialiste a conclu monsieur
mitterrand entend bien être de plus en
plus le recours du peuple de la touche
mesrine mort la ferme et sereine n'est
pas terminée loin de là le commissaire
devos patron de la brigade de répression
du banditisme poursuit va pas ensemble
de l'enquêté il va s'attacher à
reconstituer les actions de jacques
mesrine disant sa cavale reconstitue
aussi son organisation son réseau
complicité bref démonter le mécanisme de
mesrine le point blanquette par gérard y
naît dans l'appartement de la rue
belliard appartement que mesrine
s'apprêtait à quitter pour mardi le roi
le commissaire devos a déjà trouvé de
quoi travailler un incroyable arsenal
des kilos de dossiers et une quarantaine
de cas c'est ce soir la ferme istres in
a deux aspects pour les policiers
premier aspect reconstituer le réseau de
complicités de mesrine
deuxième aspect la personnalité de
l'estrie déjà avec l'enregistrement
réalisé par mesrine le 10 septembre
dernier lors de l'embuscade tendue à
jacques tillier
les enquêteurs ont acquis la certitude
que charles bauer arrêté vendredi après
midi était bien l'homme qui accompagnait
mesrine
quand le journaliste de minute fut
blessé il semble aussi se confirmer
qu'au bon air a participé à l'enlèvement
du milliardaire de la sarthe en relief
les policiers ont en effet retrouvé au
domicile de son ami plus de deux cent
mille francs qui constituait une partie
de la rançon de 6 millions de francs
versés par la famille jolienne ce soir
charles bauer et son ami ont été
présentés au parquet de paris est
inculpé de recel et de détention d'armes
il reste aux enquêteurs à retrouver deux
autres complices de mesrine françois bès
et michel sayegh ski deuxième aspect la
divulgation et c'est une chose
inhabituelle comme l'est la ferme et
screen d'un certain nombre
d'enregistrements réalisés par mesrine
enregistrement communiqué par le
procureur de la république et qui bien
entendu n'apparaissent pas comme faisant
partie des instructions en cours
alors c'est cassette qui se trouve donc
hors des procédures d'instruction
nous avons décidé de ne pas les diffuser
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'elle
ne présente aucun intérêt je dire aucune
information nouvelle sur l' enquête en
cours et que s'agissant d'enregistrement
personnel destiné par jacques mesrine à
sa maîtresse toujours vivante elle
relève du domaine de la vie privée d'un
homme quel qu'il soit et d'une femme
ensuite parce qu'il est apparu à la
rédaction d'antenne 2 que ce genre de
diffusion relèverait de ces choses
troubles dont on accuse souvent la
presse de se repaître de mai l'émission
question de temps de jean pierre
elkabbach lui berio a pour titre ces
hommes qui s'aiment elle comprend une
enquête reportage de l'écrivain
dominique fernandez de notre confrère le
bitoux du journal le guêpier et patricia
mallette d'antenne et c'est un ensemble
de reportages sur la vie quotidienne des
homosexuels et c'est la première fois
depuis un dossier de l'écran d'il ya
quatre ans environ que la télévision
française consacre un programme
d'information de longue durée à ces
questions il s'agit tout à la fois de
rompre un certain silence de ne pas
s'arrêter devant des tabous et de
traiter d'un sujet difficile mais la
difficulté n'a jamais revu t question de
temps patricia charnelet nous présente
en détail cette soirée de demain
il y en france près de 4 millions
d'homosexuels
pourtant il nous a fallu des mois de
recherches pour en trouver 12 12 hommes
qui acceptent de parler à la télévision
pourquoi et bien tout simplement par
peur d'être montrée du doigt dans leur
famille ou même dans leur travail
alors faute de pouvoir vivre à visage
découvert eh bien ces femmes se
rencontrent dans des endroits comme les
jardins publics comme ce parc des
tuileries
l'existence d'un tel lieu de drague est
sans doute la preuve que ces hommes
éprouvent beaucoup de difficultés à se
faire reconnaître par les autres gars
dit qu'il comprenait ce vrai maladie je
suis étranger c'est vraiment la deal
pour elle et pour finir à la gc ca
pourquoi parce que son pouls parce que
c'est la maladie c'est une seule heure
qu'est ce que je peux dire que ça j'ai
comme ceux d'air
malgré tout comme le mouvement c'est
vrai fou c'est pas comblé faut c'est
vrai pour il ya deux sortes
d'homosexuels et d'avancer qu'ils sont
malades et ceux qui font ça pour de
l'argent alors c'est déjà deux choses
différentes
il ya soixante dix ans que je suis dans
le parti de jouer là savaient à traiter
en tant que j'avais un quartier 4 t3
puis les pour yves et qu'est-ce qu'il
vous autres qu'est ce qui vous en fait
il en sourit je pense que
les femmes ça ne me plaît pas du tout
des hommes ça ne fait pas du tout partie
ne parlait pas moins regarde comment
jugez vous les hommes qui aiment les
hommes
puisque c'est pas normal c'est un risque
quoi paraît-il dans ma maison il y en a
ça vous gêne je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai je me pose la question si c'est
exact
j'ai beaucoup vous aimez pas pourquoi je
pense
sauf que c'est
je sais pas j'ai pas l'usure du car ont
franchement value en réponse à ces
jugements un enseignant un agriculteur
un architecte expliqueront qu'ils ne
sont pas des monstres
une mère de famille dira tout simplement
que si deux garçons vivent ensemble et
bien c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'ils
aiment à la suite du film un débat animé
par louis blériot permettra de dépasser
la traditionnelle discussions d'ordre
psychologique ou morale pour poser la
question de la répression qui existe à
l'encontre des homosexuels comme dans
les lois et plus généralement de
l'attitude des partis politiques et de
la société
en fait jean pierre elkabbach et louis
blériot ne vous demande pas de prendre
parti pour et contre ses hommes qui
s'aiment mais de les écouter peut-être
après avoir suivi ce programme
une partie du public montrera-t-elle
plus de tolérance que les personnes que
nous venons d'entendre question de temps
commencera vers 20h40 35 ter notre
journal télévisé sera un peu plus long
que d'habitude il comportera en effet
une page spéciale sur le cambodge un
pays où sévit la famine ravagé par la
guerre après le régime impitoyable des
khmers rouges
gérard ce bac b jean françois renaud
sont entrés au cambodge avec des
éléments armés de la troisième force h
analystes lesquels se battent contre les
vietnamiens avec mes rouge
ils ont découvert l'ampleur du drame les
images sont très dures rappelons que
demain s'ouvre demain justement revenu
la conférence internationale humanitaire
sur l'aide au cambodge réuni à
l'initiative de la france hier aux états
unis en caroline du nord à gainsbourg où
une fusillade a fait quatre morts et dix
blessés
à l'origine une manifestation de rue
organisées contre le culte luxe clan
l'organisation ultra raciste par un
groupe communiste américain brusquement
des membres de l'organisation raciale
arrive dans voiture une bagarre des
oppose aux manifestants des armes fusils
pistolets sortent du kop des automobiles
des coups de feu venant des parts de
chacun des deux groupes mais les quatre
victimes sont toutes membres de
l'organisation kabiliste douze personnes
se réclamant du ku klux klan ont été
arrêtés et accusés de meurtre avec
préméditation en bolivie après le récent
coup d'état grève générale déclenchée
contre le nouveau président le colonel
la touche bush
selon les dirigeants syndicaux la grève
se poursuivra jusqu'à la démission du
colonel alors que l'armée elle soutient
le nouveau régime mais aucun pays
étranger ne l'a encore connue
moi je rappelle que l'état est bien que
les militaires contrôlent apparemment le
pays sans difficulté le colonel albert
thomas tous bush semble avoir bien du
mal à asseoir son nouveau pouvoir
l'opposition interne au nouveau chef de
l'état se manifeste jusque dans la rue
barricades défilé populaire ses marques
de réprobation sont appuyés par tous les
secteurs d'opinion bolivien partis
politiques les syndicats qui
maintiennent leur pression par une
nouvelle général cette prime ne s'achève
pas a déclaré le leader qu'avec la
démission de l'auteur du coup d'état
après les manifestations d'hier soir au
cours desquelles une jeune femme a été
tuée au cours des affrontements avec la
police militaire le colonel la touche a
décrété la loi martiale le couvre feu et
la censure de la presse
ces décisions font passer au second plan
une déclaration du nouveau président
bolivien affirmant que le nouveau régime
militaire serait relativement bref
la cisjordanie territoire occupé par
israël est au centre des conversations
de paix au proche-orient vous le savez
il ya quelques jours nous vous avons
présenté ici même la vie de la colonie
juive d'elon moreh celle là même dont la
cour suprême israélienne a demandé
l'évacuation
aujourd'hui à quelques kilomètres à
peine des liens de marée dans le camp de
batam
c'est le climat chez les palestiniens de
cisjordanie que philippe gassot a tenté
de préciser paume
il a fallu longuement parlementer pour
obtenir quelques avis des habitants du
camp car ici si l'on peut parler de tout
un sujet est proscrit la politique qu'on
laisse à quelques palestiniens
officielle est que le mot est prononcé
qu'on se trouve immédiatement un travail
urgent à faire qui ne peut pas attendre
et la crainte est visible le mouvement
de recul est immédiat si j'étais autre
part que dans ce camp surveillé par
l'armée israélienne dont on ne sort pas
le soir après cette heure je pourrais
vous parler mais pas si les plus motivés
ont pourtant accepté après bien des
hésitations avec la promesse qu'il ne
serait pas reconnaissable mais cette
défaite est difficile de parler des
problèmes de drogue oui c'est difficile
vous rappeler ce qui s'est passé pour ou
quelques français qui parlait politique
durant l'occupation nazie en france
alors que plus d'efforts si vous
regardez la caméra est il arrivé à 30
bichon tir en prison ce qui est condamné
c'est l'armée israélienne avec ses
patrouilles ces postes d'observation
autour du camp ainsi que ces contrôles
ils savent tous ici que les ultra
nationalistes d'elon moreh sur leurs
voisins depuis 6 ils savent aussi qu'ils
ne peuvent rien faire pour changer les
choses
les décisions sont prises ailleurs alors
on ne fait que constater du point de vue
palestinien que la paix est encore loin
que pensez-vous des lots de mort et vous
qui vivez juste à côté à quelques
kilomètres le gouvernement israélien a
chassé beaucoup de palestiniens vivent
sur cette terre nous emporte
il a pris cette partie de la palestine
il y a mis ses installations
les palestiniens d'ici n'apprécie pas un
tel comportement
ils pensent que ce n'est pas un bon
moyen pour la paix c'est contre la paix
peace de cette paix possible on en parle
beaucoup ici la haine du peuple juif si
elles existent n'apparaît nulle part les
juifs et les arabes ont tout le temps
vécu ensemble c'est donc possible dit-on
à l'intérieur d'une maison que l'on
préfère garder anonyme où sont accrochés
des reproduction interdite et retiré de
la vente qui symbolise la mort d'une
écolière palestinienne et le peuple
palestinien enchaîné pas une fois il a
été question de la disparition d'israël
cette notion paraît complètement
dépassés ce qui est sensible
c'est ce besoin énorme que le général
dayal lui-même avait souligné celui de
la dignité et qui oblige à s'intéresser
à tout ce qui se passe à tel aviv ou à
jérusalem
même si la règle ou l'habitude demeure
la méfiance à vous intéressez vous à ce
qui se passe en israël les palestiniens
sont très intéressés par ce qui se passe
économiquement et politiquement facteurs
oui nous lisons les journaux et les
magazines et nous écoutons la radio pour
savoir ce qui se passe tout aussi parce
que cela a des effets très importants
sur notre vie
et nous avons à propos des jeunes gens
dont le mouvement s'appelle la paix
maintenant
peace now que pensez-vous 2 nous avons
entendu dire qu'ils veulent la paix avec
les arabes veille
white très peace à la bible mais ils ne
font pas ce qu'ils devraient faire pour
nous il devrait faire plus du off ne
pense pas qu'il s'agit là d'un début
c'est peut-être un début mais on n'a pas
encore vu le résultat de cette paix
peace with a fait le signe de la
trézence can you go entre vous dans la
rue un jour avec eux nous avons vu le
début c'est un très pauvre commencement
games week nous ne pouvons pas décider
maintenant ce n'est pas de notre fait
c'est l'ump qui décidera isabelle et
wintek et de ces gens les gens simples
de batam ont besoin qu'on leur trouve
que la paix c'est autre chose qu'un mot
ou qu'un souhait pour peut-être
commencer à y croire comme certains ont
commencé à le faire de l'autre côté
s'il ya une chose dont on est sûr en
france c'est que nos vins sont les
meilleurs du monde bien voilà un
chauvinisme gastronomique qui n'est plus
tout à fait de saison après le grand
marathon des vins du monde auquel ont
pris part 33 pays présentant total 333
cru une compétition organisée par nos
confrères qui se terminait au françois
les vins français demeure en tête du
classement général mais dans plusieurs
catégories ils ont été nettement battu
par des vins venus de très loin le
danger pour nos exportations n'est pas
encore immédiat à la condition que nos
producteurs ne s'endorment pas sur leurs
lauriers ni vers ses pages un reportage
mais sans dégustation lalinde risque
imaginons un instant que les chinois ils
sont près de 1 milliard se mettent à
exporter du bon vin cataclysme
économique fleuve rouge se répandant sur
la planète
stop c'est un cauchemar qui n'est pas
près de se réaliser
les vins chinois sont catastrophiques
c'est ce qui ressort de la dégustation
marathon par contre des vins
californiens australien espagnol ou néo
zélandais domine aujourd'hui en qualité
certains vins français par exemple dans
les bourgogne blancs cépage chardonnay
la france arrive 7e sauvignon nous
sommes quatrièmes bourgogne rouge le
pinot noir australien est en tête
le bordelais n'est pas épargné un rioja
espagnol devance un château latour 1970
que les alsaciens ne se réjouissent pas
trop vite c'est un riesling néo
zélandais qui a décroché la première
place dans cette catégorie
parmi les nouveaux talents il y a les
amériques mais de l'avis même d'un
américain grand connaisseur il n'y a pas
de quoi s'inquiéter
je pense que certains vases américain
atteigne effectivement le niveau de très
grands vins français
mais ils sont produits en très petite
quantité pour l'instant états unis et la
quasi-totalité du même dans l'état de
californie
il suffit à peine
pour hbo aux états unis l'intérêt du vin
et est galopante là bas et même à new
york il est difficile d fois de trouver
du bon vin en californie donc la france
n'ont rien à craindre d'une invasion
massive des amériques
quant aux anglais citoyens d'albion ont
dit qu'ils sont perfides alors
profiteront qu'il du résultat de ces
dégustations pour nous faire de la peine
et acheter leurs vins ailleurs que chez
nous des vins français sont extrêmement
connu et puis je crois le prix égal les
gens aiment aimé acheter 20 français que
l'âge qu'on paye mais je ne pense pas
que cette confrontation internationale
pas toujours très favorable aux vins
français risque de porter atteinte à
l'image de marque de nos vins je pense
pas ça peut ça peut valoriser un peu les
autres vins mais je pense que le fait
qu'un vin français devient 3e 4e après
un vin mais qu'un maintien c'est plutôt
pour prendre les échevins que fo ne pas
vendre les vins français souhaitons
alors que les anglais ne tombe pas dans
le panneau publicitaire que dresseront
nos concurrents en exploitant les
résultats de ces tests
résultat qui devrait faire grincer les
dents des professionnels français
le consommateur lui a peut être beaucoup
payent gagner il faut que les olives et
huiles perles élèves ayant réagi se
disent nous ne sommes pas les seuls et
surtout il faut qu'ils vendent vendent à
l'étranger parce que les fonctions pour
boire énormément et dix ans ont d'abord
eu un petit peu moins qu'avant et
ensuite on voit des meilleurs vins
qu'avant donc il faut que tout le monde
le niveau généralement de telle sorte
qu'on puisse vente du vin à l'étranger
et les étrangers pour comparer et vont
se dire à tous vas portugais souffre
l'espagnol a italienne est largement
aussi bon que la france et pourquoi ce
qu'on a choisi la france et les
vignerons qui ne se tuent ne comprennent
pas ça va se casser la figure et il y
aura encore des drames ce serait bien
dommage
il faut réagir et ce qu'ils ne réagiront
pas seront punis par leur chauvinisme
je t'ai une sorte de paresse si la
france remporte largement la première
place au classement général devant les
usa
elle gagne aussi la médaille d'or du
prix du vin le plus élevé du monde à
auteuil le grand prix d'automne à
handicap sur les haies a été extrêmement
spectaculaire le public hésiter
tellement entre les concurrents que le
premier favori est parti à près de 8
contre 1 c'est une sorte de record la
victoire est revenue à pabos real qui
appartient à un journaliste bien connu
dans le sud est
jean-claude sur le voici le dernier
kilomètre de la course ou à peu plus
cette course qui est une distance de
4100 mètres peu de chevaux sont tombés
et c'est actuellement appartenant aux
cheveux noirs et aux belges échiquier un
ancien très bon cheval qui est parti de
très loin
il est en tête il mène tandis que faire
comme à madame leblanc kazakh blanche
coque rouge va rétrograder
il n'a plus ses jambes de jadis à
l'extérieur casaque rose complètement à
l'extérieur et venant maintenant
deuxième position prendre la deuxième
position et et pâques voici un cheval
dont on a peu parlé il a quatre ans et
pas vino pavie nos qui est amené de très
loin par chirol peut être d'un peu trop
loin
et puis c'est l'avant dernière haie nous
avons pas vino à droite là il est en
pleine piste tandis que échiquier va
céder et kazakh cercles et gris et
orange
voici à vauréal pas boréale qui se
promènent des eaux ce type d obstacles
aux courses plates mais qui entraînait
par arthur bats est monté par cholet
concert une forme remarquable pav
innocentant peup choquant est la
dernière et est ce qui avait appuyé sa
chance croyez en mon expérience
personnelle je pensais pas ce moment là
qu'il avait gagné et chic et toque
blanche odin dernier rapport perles des
chaumes des courageuses
la courageuse bien à droite il n'y a
rien à faire à vauréal
gagne et il va conserver une tête sur
pas vino qui a terminé le long de la lys
du pesage 7 9 8 des chevaux du centre de
l'échelle des poids
dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 1338 50 ordre
différent de son enfant ce n'est pas
prêt très bien payé mais l'important
comme disait l'autre est touché dans la
mythologie des sports spectacles les six
jours cyclistes une place particulière
de grands champions sur la piste les
sprints fabuleux une ambiance me snobent
mythes populaires et les poursuites des
chasses comme l'on disait entre coureurs
déchaîné jusqu'à l'aube
le vélodrome d'hiver de paris n'existe
plus rue nélaton depuis une vingtaine
d'années à ma part dans la construction
bientôt dit on du prochain vélodrome à
bercy mais les six jours continuent
d'exister au vélodrome de grenoble et
avec jean paul ollivier promenons nous
dans leurs coulisses c'est à dire entre
la piste et ce qu'on appelle les kenyans
et ces 10e 6 jours de la ville de
grenoble connaissent un succès les
records d'affluence risque d'être battu
durant ce week-end en tête pour l'heure
alors que la chasse du dimanche soir va
commencer ou hammam commencé il ya
quelques instants
les positions sont les suivantes en tête
le tandem schuiten brawn qui étaient ici
en tête d'ailleurs suite n devant moser
epinay
le restaurant le parterre comme l'on dit
bat des records lui aussi et ce n'est
pas le patron de ces six jours et du
critérium du dauphiné libéré
georges cazeneuve que voici qui nous
démentira
du côté des vedettes un problème pour
patrick sercu qui étaient ici en
compagnie de guy lapébie patrick circuit
le recordman des victoires en six jours
il a perdu dès vendredi soir son
coéquipier l'allemand dietrich tuera ou
qui se ressent d'une chute au coude
survenue aux six jours de francfort du
rao qui subissent et chaque soir un
traitement à la novocaïne a préféré
abandonner le règlement lui donné 24
heures pour trouver un coéquipier
il l'a trouvé en la personne de bernard
vallet qui est un peu l'enfant du pays
et s'est trouvée libre à la suite de
l'abandon de patrick cluzaud coéquipiers
en temps normal de bernard in
ici c'est la séance d'échauffement
traditionnels lorsque durant la journée
la course est neutralisée beaucoup moins
d'heures de celle qu auparavant
mais les professionnels n'en finissent
pas moins à deux heures chaque nuit
après grenoble paris attend donc son
nouveau vel d'hiv
tandis que les dirigeants sportifs de la
ville de brest venue à grenoble
s'apprête aussi à construire un palais
des sports en tous cas grenoble bouclera
mardi prochain les millièmes six jours
de l'histoire le temps demain bien les
prévisions de la météo centre est simple
tant ce veiller sur les régions
méridionales
ailleurs temps faiblement pluvieux et
doux suivi de quelques éclaircies sur le
nord-ouest grande ouest modéré et assez
fort en avant de terminer la présente
édition je dirais encore que ces
piranhas